Merhaba sevgili öğrenciler. Kanalıma hoş
geldiniz. Bu dersimizde 9. sınıfın 7.
teması olan Life in the work nature
dünyada, doğada yaşam adlı üniteyi hep
birlikte işleyeceğiz.
Eğer bu ünite ile ilgili alıştırmalar,
testler, denemeler çözmek istiyorsanız,
öğrendiğiniz kelimelerle ilgili oyunlar
oynamak istiyorsanız Play Store ve App
Store'dan ücretsiz bir şekilde Justin
Academ uygulamasını indirip
kullanabilirsiniz. Yeni müfredata göre
yeni içerikler hazırlanıyor. Mutlaka
ziyaret edin. Kalem ve kağıdınız hazırsa
dersimize başlıyoruz. Endangered
animals, nesi tükenmek üzere olan
hayvanlar.
Polar Bear, kutup ayısı.
Çimpanzi, şempze.
Sea turtle, deniz kaplumbağası.
Penguin penguen.
Dolphin, yunus balığı
tiger kaplan
whale balina
great white shark büyük beyaz köpek
balığı
volt IB kelaynak.
Nesli tükenmek üzere olan hayvanların
ingilizce isimlerini öğrendik. Şimdi
sırada habitat yani yaşam alanları var.
Shelter barınak.
Desert çöl.
Grassland otlak çayır.
Ocean okyanus.
Rain forest yağmur ormanı.
Jungle karışık orman.
Forest orman.
Woodland. Ağaçlık, ormanlık.
Sıradaki konu threats and problems.
Tehlikeler ve problemler.
Endanger nesli tükenmek üzere olan.
Extinction nesli tükenmiş.
Deforestation orman tahribatı.
Habitat loss, doğal yaşam alanının
kaybı.
Overfishing gereğinden fazla balık
avlamak.
Overhunting aşırı avlanmak.
Air pollution hava kirliliği.
Marine pollution deniz kirlenmesi.
Disease hastalık.
Climate change. İklim değişikliği.
Global warming. Küresel ısınma.
Conservation and actions. Korumalar
veali.
Protect korumak.
Save kurtarmak. Korumak. Survive.
Hayatta kalmak.
Prevent. Önlemek.
Volunteers gönüllüler.
Support destek olmak. Important
vocabulary. Buünitede bulunan ve mutlaka
bilmeniz gereken kelimeler şunlardır.
Hunt, avlanmak,
illegal, yasal olmayan. Threaten, tehdit
etmek.
Deal with, baş etmek cause. Sebep olmak
population nüfus
need. ihtiyaç duymak.
Reduce azaltmak
renewable yenilenebilir.
Food sources yiyecek kaynakları.
Dedicated kendini işini adamış.
İngilizcenin en temel yapılarından olan
ve her zaman karşınıza gelecek olan was
ve ver alıplarını birlikte en ince
ayrıntısına kadar işleyeceğiz. Was ver
kalıpları geçmiş zamanı anlamanın en
temel yoludur. Geçmiş zamandaki isim
cümlelerinde kullanılır. Peki bu isim
cümlesi nedir? İçerisinde hareket
bildirmeyen yani make içermeyen
cümlelere isim cümlesi diyoruz. Yürümek,
koşmak, zıplamak, şarkı söylemek gibi
eylemlerin olmadığı cümleler isim
cümleleridir. Bunların geçmiş zamanki
hallerinde was ve were kullanılır.
Aslında was ve were bizim şu an şimdiye
anlatırken kullandığımız is, are
yardımcı fiillerinin geçmiş zamandaki
halleridir.
Eğer was ve were iyi bir şekilde
anlarsanız geçmiş zamanın mantığını daha
iyi kavrarsınız. Ayrıntısıyla işleyelim.
Positive form olumlu hal demektir.
Dersin başında was ve were kalıplarının
aslında to be fiili olan is
yapılarının geçmiş zamandaki halleridir
dedim.
I öznesi ile birlikte kullanılır. He,
she ve it özneleri ile birlikte is
kullanılır. Theyy, we, you özneleri ile
birlikte are yardımcı eki kullanılır.
Bunlar Türkçede to be fiilleri dediğimiz
is, are yapılarıdır.
Örneğin, ı doctor. Ben bir doktorum.
She is at home. O evde. They are
generous. Onlar cömerttir. Gördüğünüz
gibi bunlar geniş zamanda bulunan isim
cümleleridir. Yani içerisinde herhangi
bir eylem makeı bir ifade yoktur. Böyle
cümlelerde to be fiillerini
kullanıyoruz.
Eğer biz bu yapıları kullanıp ama geçmiş
zamanda isim cümlesi yapmak istiyorsak
ı, he, she ve it özneleri ile birlikte
was, they, we, you özneleri ile birlikte
ise were kullanacağız. Gördüğünüz gibi
özneler bizim için çok önemli. Çünkü
özneye göre yapı değişiyor. Şimdi teker
teker inceleyelim.
I, he, she ve it özneleri ile birlikte
wasz yazacağız. Daha sonra cümlenin
devamını bir isimle bitireceğiz.
Örnekleri inceleyelim. I was a pilot.
Ben bir pilottum. Geçmiş zamanda
pilotmuş. Artık pilotluk yapmıyor ya da
emekli oldu. Bunu anlatırken özlesi ile
birlikte geçmiş zamanda isim
cümlelerinde was kullanacağız.
He was il. O hasta. Erkek öznelerinde he
de kullanabiliriz ya da herhangi bir
isim de ekleyebiliriz. Geçmiş zamanda
isim cümlesi yaparken was kullanacağız.
She was sleepy. O uykulu. She yerine
yine herhangi bir isim yazabiliriz.
Geçmiş zamanda isim cümlesi olduğu için
she'den sonra was kullanacağız. It was
very hot. O çok sıcak. It hava durumunu
temsil eder. It'le birlikte was
kullanacağız. Şimdi geriye kalan
özneleri inceleyelim.
They onlar, we, biz, you, sen, siz
demektir. Bu öznelerle birlikte were
kullanacağız. W'den sonra yine bir isim
ekleyeceğiz. They were in the park.
Onlar parktaydı. Geçmiş zamanda
parktaydılar. They özesinden sonra were
kullanacağım. You were handsome. Sen
yakışıklıydın. You öznesinden sonra
geçmiş zamanda isim cümlesi yapmak
istiyorsam were kullanacağım. Ahmet and
were singers. Ahmet ve Selin
şarkıcılardı. Geçmiş zamanda şarkıcıydı.
Demek ki şimdi yapmıyorlar. Ahmet ve
Selin çoğul özne olduğu için çoğul
öznelerden sonra ver kullanacağız.
Dikkat edin burada Ahmet'i ve Selin'i
görünce hemen kız erkek diye düşünüp was
diyebilirsiniz ama yanılmayın. Çoğul
olduğu için çoğul özelerle birlikte were
kullanacağız.
The cups were on the table. Fincanlar
masanın üstündeydi. Gördüğünüz gibi
çoğullara bir tane daha örnek.
İngilizcede çoğul yapı yaparken
nesnelerin sonuna s takısı getiririz.
Burada da the cups çoğul olmuştur.
Çoğullardan sonra geçmiş zamanda were
kullanırız. Negative form olumsuz hal
demektir. Olumsuz halleri oldukça kolay
birlikte inceleyelim.
Yine her zamanki gibi öznelere dikkat
edeceğiz.
He, she ve it özneleri ile birlikte bu
sefer was'ın olumsuz hali olan wasn't'ı
kullanacağız. Uzun bir halde was not
şeklinde yazılır ama genelde kısa
göreceksiniz. Yine cümlenin sonunu bir
isimle bitireceğiz.
Örnekleri inceleyelim. I wasn't happy.
Ben mutlu değildim. Geçmiş zamanda mutlu
değildim. Bunu anlatırken sonra negatif
yapabilmek için wasn't kullanacağım.
He wasn't slim. O zayıf değildi. Demek
ki geçmişte şişmanmış. Bunu belirtirken
he erkek özesinden sonra wasn't
kullanacağım.
She wasn't at school yesterday. O dün
okulda değildi. She özdesinden sonra
geçmiş zamanda isim cümlesini negatif
yapabilmek için wasn't kullanacağım.
The car wasn't old. Araba eski değildi.
The car it öznesi yerine geçer. Bu
öznelerde olumsuz yapmak için wasn't
kullanacağım. Gördüğünüz gibi her özneye
göre teker teker inceliyorum ki aklınıza
daha iyi yerleşsin. Geriye kalan
özneleri inceleyelim. Day, we, you. Bu
öznelerden sonra were, weren't olarak
değişir. Uzun hali were not'tır. Ama
yine her zaman kısa hali tercih
edilecek. Bundan sonra yine bir isim
gelecek. Örnekleri inceleyelim. They
weren't at home. Onlar evde değillerdi.
Demek ki dışarıda bir yerdeler. Evde
değiller demek için they'den sonra
olumsuz yapabilmek için weren kullandık.
We weren't at the seaside last summer.
Geçen yaz biz deniz kenarında değildik.
Geçmiş zamanda isim cümlesi yapmak
istiyoruz ama öznemiz we. We
öznesdesinden sonra negatif isim cümlesi
yapacaksak weren kullanacağız. You
weren't kind. Sen kibar değildin. You
özesinden sonra olumsuz yapabilmek için
weren kullanılır. Peki çoğulları nasıl
yapacağız? Tom and Bill weren best
friends. Tom ve Bill yakın arkadaş
değillerdi. Geçmişte yakın değiller
anlaşamıyorlar. Çoğul özne olduğu için,
birden fazla kişiden bahsettiği için
kullandık. Question form soru hali
demektir.
Geçmişle ilgili soru sorduğumuzda şu
şekilde sorabiliriz. Bu sefer was
cümlenin başına gelecek ve ondan sonra
özneler gelecek. Yani ikisi yer
değiştiriyor. Ardından isim ekleyip soru
işaretini kullandık mı çok güzel bir
cümle elde etmiş olacağız.
Örnekleri inceleyelim. Was she hard
working? O çalışkan mıydı? Gördüğünüz
gibi bu kez wasla özne yer değiştirdi.
Eğer çalışkansa yes she was. Ama eğer
çalışkan değilse no she wasn't
diyebiliriz. Was it rainy yesterday? Dün
yağmurlu muydu? Soru olduğu için was ve
özne yer değiştirdi. Eğer yağmurluysa,
"Yes, it was". Ama eğer yağmurlu
değilse, no, it wasn't diyeceğiz. Were
ilgili soru sorduğumuzda mantık yine
aynı olacak. Yani cümleye were ile
başlayacağız. Ardından özneleri
yazacağız. Bir tane isim yazdıktan sonra
soru işareti kullanacağız.
Örnekleri inceleyelim. Were they in the
supermarket? Onlar süpermarkette miydi?
They onlar demektir. Soru yaparken
ikisinin yeri değişecek. Eğer cevap
vereceksek olumlu cevaplarda yes they
were. Olumsuz cevaplarda no they weren't
kullanacağız.
Were you bored? Sen sıkıldın mı?
Gördüğünüz gibi were ve özne yer
değiştirdi.
Cevap verirken yes ı was. Olumsuz cevap
verirken ı wasn't.
Dikkat ederseniz you diye sorduğu için
sen cevabında ben diye cevap veririz.
Time expression zaman ifadeleri
demektir. Geçmiş zamandan bahsederken
kullanabileceğimiz kelimeler var.
Yesterday dün demektir. Last kelimesi de
çok kullanılır. Last week geçen hafta.
Last year geçen yıl. Last month geçen
ay. Ag önce anlamı katar. 10 weeks ago.
10 hafta önce. Bir tane örnek
inceleyelim. I was at the bank
yesterday. Ben dün bankadaydım.
They were very hungry last night. Geçen
gece onlar çok açtı.
She was in France two years ago. 2 yıl
önce o Fransa'daydı.
Gördüğünüz gibi bu zaman ifadeleri de
bize herhangi bir konuda ipucu
verebilir. Her zaman karşımıza çıkacak
olan günlük hayatta çok fazla kullanılan
şırıt kalıbını birlikte inceleyeceğiz.
Karşımızdaki insana herhangi bir
tavsiyede bulunup öğüt vermek istiyorsak
şırıt ifadesini kullanabiliriz.
Cümlelere meli malı anlamı katar.
Yapmalısın, etmelisin, gitmelisin gibi.
Unutmayalım amacımız karşıdaki
arkadaşımıza, herhangi birine bir
tavsiyede bulunmak, bir öğüt vermektir.
Positive form olumlu hal demektir.
Shut ifadesini kullanmak çok kolay çünkü
öznelere göre hiçbir zaman değişmez.
Ben, you s. We, Biz. They onlar. He
erkekler için kullanılır. O demektir.
She kızlar için kullanılır. O demektir.
It cansız ve hayvanlarda kullanılır. O
demektir. Gördüğünüz bütün bu öznelerden
sonra shut ifadesini yazabiliriz. Bunu
yazdıktan sonra cümlenin devamı olan
fiili kullanırız. Ama gördüğünüz gibi
çok kolay çünkü hiçbir özneye göre
değişikliğe uğramadı. I have a fever.
Benim ateşim var.
You should have a rest. Sen
dinlenmelisin. Gördüğünüz gibi karşıdaki
bir insana tavsiyede bulunuyoruz. Bunu
yapmalısın demek istiyoruz. O yüzden
should kullandık. You should drink water
everyday. Sen her gün su içmelisin.
Should cümlelere melih malı anlamı
katar. Karşıdaki kişiye tavsiyede
bulunacaksak bu yapıyı kullanabiliriz.
I should study for the exam. Ben sınav
için çalışmalıyım. Bunu yapmam
gerekiyor. Çalışmalıyım. Bu anlamı
katmak için should kullanacağız. We
should go to bed early. Biz yatağa erken
gitmeliyiz. Bunu yapmamız gerekiyor.
Çünkü sağlığımız için önemli. Bu yüzden
bu cümlede should kullandık.
She should call her grandmother.
Today is her birthday. O büyükannesini
aramalı. Bugün onun doğum günü. Yapması
gerekiyor. Bu anlamı katabilmek için
should kullandık. The weather is rainy.
You should take your umbrella. Hava
yağmurlu. Sen şemsiyeni almalısın. Bunu
yapman gerekiyor. Sana tavsiye olarak
söylüyorum ve cümlelerime mimalı anlam
katmak istiyorum. O halde bana yardımcı
olacak şey şut kalıbıdır. Negative form
olumsuz hal demektir. Eğer bu yapıyı
kullanıp olumsuz bir cümle yapacaksak
shouldn't kullanmalıyız.
Should not olarak da yazılır ama genelde
siz bunu shouldn't olarak göreceksiniz.
Kullanımı yine çok kolay. Cümlelere
öznelerle başlayacağız ve öznelerimizi
yansıtıktan sonra olumsuz yapabilmek
için shouldn't'ı kullanacağız. Ardından
fiillerimizi ekleyeceğiz.
You shouldn't eat too much junkwood. Sen
çok fazla abur cubur yememelisin.
Yapmaman gerekiyor. Sağlığın için kötü.
Olumsuz bir tavsiyede bulunacağım için
shouldn't kullandım. I shouldn't drive
so fast. Çok hızlı bir şekilde araba
sürmemeliyim. Bunu yapmamam gerekiyor.
Olumsuz bir tavsiyeye ihtiyacım var. Bu
yüzden shouldn't kullandım. She
shouldn't drink cold water. O soğuk su
içmemeli. Bunu yapmaması gerekiyor. Eğer
negatif bir uyarıda bulunacaksak,
tavsiye vereceksek shouldn't
kullanmalıyız. He shouldn't spend too
much money. O çok fazla para
harcamamalı. Bunu yapmaması gerekiyor.
Bu yüzden shouldn't kullanacağız. Jack
is fat. He should eat many hamburgers.
Jack şişman. O çok fazla hamburger
yememeli. Bunu yapmaması gerekiyor. Bu
yüzden shouldn't kullandık. Question
form soru hali demektir. Eğer bunu
yapmalı mıyım, şunu yapmalı mısın diye
soru soracaksak şu şekilde sorular
sorabiliriz.
Bu sefer should ve özne yer
değiştirecek. Cümleye should ile
başlayacağız. Ardından öznelerden bir
tanesini kullanacağız. Özneleri
yazdıktan sonra fiilimizi ekleyeceğiz.
Soru işareti kullandık mı çok güzel bir
cümle elde etmiş oluyoruz.
Should I take pain killer? Ben ağır
kesiciç almalı mıyım? Gördüğünüz gibi
should ve özne yer değiştirdi.
Alması gerektiği için yes you should
diyebiliriz. Evet almalısın. Should he
eat junkwood. O abur cubur yemeli mi?
Yememesi gerekiyor. Bu yüzden no he
shouldn't diyeceğiz.
Should they do exercise. Onlar egzersiz
yapmalı mı? should ve özne yer
değiştirdi. Böylece soru cümlesi elde
etmiş olduk. Eğer yapması gerekiyorsa
yes they should ama eğer yapması
gerekmiyorsa no they shouldn't
kullanmalıyız.
İngilizcede temel yapılardan bir diğeri
olan ve her zaman göreceğimiz önemli
kalıplardan bir tanesi must ifadesidir.
Bu dersimizde must'ı en ince ayrıntısına
kadar birlikte işleyeceğiz. Mast
cümlelere zorunluluk, mecburiyet,
gereklilik gibi anlamlar katar.
Karşıdaki insana eğer çok kuvvetli bir
tavsiyede bulunacaksak bunu yapman
gerekiyor. Yapmasan senin için sonucu
kötü olacak. Herhangi bir ceza var, bir
yaptırım var demek istiyorsak must
kullanacağız. Must ve should genellikle
karıştırılır.
Should da cümlelere melim malı anlamı
katar. Karşıdakine bir tavsiyede öğütte
bulunurken kullanacağımız yapıdan bir
tanesidir. Ama dikkat etmemiz gereken
şey şıkta herhangi bir zorunluluk yok.
Biz tavsiyeyi veriyoruz. Bu kişi yapsa
da bizi ilgilendirmez, yapmasa da
ilgilendirmez. Yapmasa sonucunda da kötü
bir şey olacak ama herhangi bir ceza,
bir yaptırım yok. Ama must ile
kurduğumuz cümlede daha kuvvetli bir
şeyden bahsediyoruz. Bunu yapmak
zorundasın. Yapmasan sonucu kötü olacak
anlamı katıyoruz. Positive form olumlu
hal demektir. Must kullanımı çok
kolaydır. Çünkü bütün özelerde aynı
şekilde kullanılır. Hiçbir değişikliğe
uğramaz. I, ben, you, sen, siz. We, biz,
they, onlar. He, erkekler için
kullanılır, o demektir. She, kızlar için
kullanılır. O demektir. It cansızlarda
ve hayvanlarda kullanılır, o demektir.
Bütün bu özelerden sonra must olduğu
haliyle kullanır, yanına fiilimizi
ekleriz.
Örnekleri inceleyelim. Zeynep musturing
milk. Zeynep süt içmeli. Büyümesi için
içmesi gerekiyor. İçmezse kemik gelişimi
olumsuz etkilenecek. Bunu yapmak
zorunda. Kuvvetli bir tavsiyede
bulunuyoruz.
O yüzden bizim ihtiyacımız olan şey must
kalıbıdır.
Ahmet must do homework. Ahmet ödevini
yapmak zorunda. Yapmazsa ya eksi alacak
ya da öğretmeni düşük not verecek.
Gördüğünüz gibi sonucunda herhangi bir
ceza, herhangi bir yaptırım var.
Everybody must fasten seat belts. Herkes
emniyet kemerini takmalı. Eğer takmazsa
sonucunda herhangi bir ceza alabilirler.
Bunu anlatırken must kullanacağız.
We must cook healthy foods. Biz sağlıklı
yiyecekler pişirmek zorundayız. Eğer
yapmazsak hastalanacağız. Sonucu bizim
için kötü olacak. Bu yüzden must
kullanmalıyız.
You must be silent at the library. Sen
kütüphanede sessiz olmak zorundasın. Bu
bir zorunluluk. Buna uymazsan dışarıya
atılabilirsin. İnsanları rahatsız
edebilirsin.
You must stop when you see the red
light. Kırmızı ışığı gördüğünde durman
gerekiyor. Durmak zorundasın. Bunu
yapmazsan ceza alabilirsin. Negative
form olumsuz hal demektir. Eğer must
kalıbını olumsuz halde kullanacaksak
must şeklinde kullanacağız. uzun haliyle
masnat diyebiliriz ama genellikle kısa
haliyle göreceksiniz.
Masnant yapısını negatif olarak
kullanacağımız için yasaklardan ve
kurallardan bahsedeceğiz.
Kullanım oldukça kolay. Yine öznelerden
bir tanesini yazacağız. Bu öznelerden
sonra olumsuz hali olan must'ı yazıp
yanına fiilimizi ekleyeceğiz.
He mustn't sleep during the class. O
sınıfta uyumamalı. Bunu yapmaması
gerekiyor. Bunu anlatırken must
kullanacağız. You mustn't smoke. Sen
sigara içmemelisin. Yapmaman gerekiyor.
Sonunda bir ceza var. Yasaktır.
Yapmamalısın. Children mustn't talk to
strangers. Çocuklar yabancılarla
konuşmamalı. Bunları yapmamaları
gerekiyor. Bu yüzden mustent
kullanacağız.
Eğer yaparlarsa sonucu kötü olacak.
Gördüğünüz gibi çok daha kuvvetli bir
tavsiye var. Question form soru hali
demektir. Must yapısını kullanıp soru
cümlesi oluşturacaksak cümleye must ile
başlayacağız. Ardından öznelerden bir
tanesini yazdıktan sonra fiili
yazacağız. Gördüğünüz gibi bu sefer must
ve özneler yer değiştirdi.
Must she take this medication. O bu ilaç
tedavisini almalı mı? Soru olduğu için
must özne yer değiştirdi. Cümleye must
ile başladık. Eğer alması gerekiyorsa
yes she must. Eğer alması gerekmiyorsa,
"No, she mustn't diyeceğiz.
Must I study with Tom?" Ben Tom'la
çalışmalı mıyım? Eğer çalışmam
gerekiyorsa yes, you must. Ama eğer
çalışmam gerekmiyorsa no, you mustn't
diyeceğiz. Beni dinlediğiniz için
teşekkür ederim. Play Store ve App
Store'dan Justin Academi uygulamasını
indirip kullanmayı unutmayın lütfen.
Hepinize şimdiden başarılar. Kendinize
iyi bakın. Görüşmek üzere.